hey it's Owen Wilson here yeah now
you're probably asking yourself wait a
minute is Owen Wilson having a Christmas
special yeah you know I am
Christmas it's the best time of the year
I don't know if there will be snow but
have a puppeteer so this is my favorite
time of the year and I have some helpful
tips for stocking stuffers because I
know how stressful stocking stuffers can
be for some people you know I don't I
don't know what to do with the stocking
stuffer well listen to Owen I got the
idea so maybe you can stuff a stocking
with uh you know what a palm tree or or
maybe maybe you just want to stock a
stalking with another stalking now I
have a very special guest on the show
you guys are gonna just jump off the
trees please welcome the one and only
the best in this holiday season please
give it up for Sinbad I mean Santa Claus
Santa bring him out why I'm sitting
Betsy come out here
hey Santa how are you
welcome to the Owen Wilson show the Owen
Wilson show
so this is very generous of me and this
holiday season I'm allowing callers to
call in and talk to Santa from the
goodness of my heart in a half hour cuz
I gotta tell Santa what I want for
Christmas so Santa so there's a lot of
things I really want this year I kind of
want you know some a couple of drum sets
you know and I like I'd like you know
some hot babes you know near the tree or
maybe maybe a mustache oh man I would
love to have a trampoline what are you
doing man Luke what do you it's not what
you think it's not what you think Luke
get out of your wife it's exactly what I
think what you what are you talking
about you got it you gotta stop oh you
gotta stop cuz what
is coming over that's great cuz west can
be an guests on my show no no no it's
not gonna be in your show he doesn't
want to be participated in anything of
your show why doesn't he want to be a
guest on the Owen Wilson show yeah no
he's not interested
finish up this you're jealous Luke
because I have Santa on as a guest and
he's gonna get me all the gifts for
Christmas I'm not jealous why would I be
jealous why would I be jealous
I'm not jealous Luke you might you might
want to just get out of here okay
fine I'll go Wow
sometimes sibling rivalry is the
scariest day you know all right well you
guys it's been a lot of fun Owen Wilson
here I'm wishing you a Merry Christmas
and a Happy New Year don't go on get out
of here open up your presents cuz that's
when it's a barrel let me know if
anything isn't for you and you want to
give it to me good bye now Duke did you
do Santa's on his way
happy Christmas only happy Christmas
week so this is Christmas and what have
you done
another year over a new where well